would Obamacare lead to death panels is
it a government takeover supporters and
the President himself are fighting back
against such claims if you met
misrepresent what's in this plan we will
call you out a lot of very deceiving
headlines out Palin we've got this fact
free paranoia it's easy to see why some
claims make them angry calm down pal
euthanasia classes aren't part of the
plan it is a lie plain and simple but
what's not a lie is that government
programs often end up doing lots of
things that weren't in politicians
original plans just look at state level
health insurance reform and it's
actually a very relaxing treatment
acupuncture may not be what uninsured
people want most but some states for its
insurance companies to cover it same for
chiropractic care nationwide there are
more than 1,500 mandates many of which
weren't part of state's original health
reform plans lobby of Gotham tacked on
after bills were made into law the
result higher premiums should the
president be looking at Massachusetts as
a model of lowering health care costs no
Massachusetts is not the model that's
for sure and mandates are one reason why
Mitt Romney's plan has become so
expensive today Massachusetts residents
pay the nation's highest premiums what
it looks like is a mess right now call
it mission cream politicians pass a
program and then the scope of the
program grows and changes from the
income tax which originally targeted to
well-off but now targets millions of
regular people
de a to the drug war whose original
emphasis on treatment gave way to DEA
raids and endless arrest why do
government officials have such a hard
time sticking to their original plans we
asked for seven hundred billion dollars
to purchase troubled assets from
financial institutions remember tarp
Congress passed it in october two
thousand eight but one year later not
one of those troubled or toxic assets
has been purchased but the money has
been used to bail out GM Chrysler and
homeowners you're using tarp now
completely differently than you told
Congress you're going to use it harp is
becoming an all-purpose slush fund I
will never apologize for before changing
an approach or strategy when the facts
change the strategy is still changing
now politicians like Nancy Pelosi want
to use tarp money for another stimulus
we really don't know the results of the
first impetus so what does all of this
mean for the current health insurance
today it means you don't have to side
with guys like him to assume that
Obamacare would eventually do all kinds
of things that aren't spelled out in
today's official plan for reason TV I'm
Nicholas
you